[Musique]
j'avais envie de montrer la vraie
dépression et pour moi la vraie
dépression c'est vraiment l'inertie
totale l'immobilisme c'est la mort
cérébrale donc qu'est-ce qu'on montre
qu'est-ce qu'on montre à part quelqu'un
qui ne bouge pas de son canapé
les signes de la dépression pour
Florence c'est que moi je me retrouve à
être appelé par elle pour venir lui
donner un coup de main parce que
vraiment elle se rend compte que ça va
pas effectivement elle mange plus elle
travaille plus elle est plus capable de
se lever de son canapé de s'habiller de
faire le minimum de se laver ça va pas
on en avait un peu marre cette semaine
là cette semaine de l'épisode 7 ouais
ouais c'était hyper dur à jouer parce
que c'est pas marrant c'est pas marrant
à jouer de d'être en dépression pourquoi
tu te combles dans la dépression là non
c'est pas tant à interpréter c'est à
figurer que c'est difficile la
dépression
je voulais être au plus près de du vrai
bah c'est très très dur de
d'intéresser avec un sujet qui est super
pas en mouvement qui est vraiment qui
est vraiment très très proche de la mort
c'est pour ça qu'on a un carnet ma
dépression avec un personnage avec un
comédien qu'est-ce que je fais
aujourd'hui je suis en train de choper
de manger
c'est de la maltraitante
moi le mouvement salut ma belle j'ai des
framboises aujourd'hui tu veux goûter
elles sont hyper bonnes
on l'appelle la mort mais en fait c'est
plus l'angoisse de Florence par rapport
à la mort
cette personnage qu'elle connaît très
bien
quelle fréquente depuis longtemps voilà
qui apparaît à n'importe quel moment
dans sa vie ça n'a pas terrifie
toujours très détendu parce que c'est
pas le moment bonsoir monsieur je vais
vous inquiétez pas je connais la
destination
je vis concrètement avec la peur de la
mort depuis que je suis toute petite je
pense que c'est un peu le cas de tout le
monde mais il y en a qui s'en a commode
et il y en a pour qui c'est vraiment ça
devient irrespirable est-ce qu'on
voulait montrer c'était cette oppression
permanente ce personnage permanent qui
l'accompagne depuis qu'elle est tout
petite qu'elle a tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps bah donc vous n'avez
rien à faire là
c'est ce que je me tue à vous dire tous
les jours mon petit bonhomme et
finalement le seul endroit où elle
l'oublie c'est sur scène moi je crois
que c'est le seul endroit où j'ai pas
peur justement
mon personnage
d'angoisse de la mort
en fait c'est en coulisses mais il est
mort de trouille
parce qu'il sent que là il a plus
d'influence il a plus d'emprise voilà
donc
peut-être plus moins de raison de vivre
ce qui m'a vérité vraiment je pense que
sur scène on ne peut pas se permettre
d'avoir une attaque de panique on peut
pas avoir une crise d'angoisse parce que
il y a des gens parce qu'on existe qu'on
surexiste on est vivant mais quand je
descends de scène bah la mort
m'accompagne en fait tout le temps vous
faites là
[Musique]
je retourne la question et moi je suis
chez moi non ce que moi je fais là ça a
été un peu le lait de motif pour créer
ce personnage on pensait à des
expressions comme la mort rode la mort
est à ses côtés la mort elle est dans
ses pas et dans son ombre danse avec la
mort et voilà et ce comédien incarne à
la perfection je dirais et de manière
ludique on va dire un petit peu cette
omniprésence de la dépression je sais
pas j'ai l'impression que je fais un AVC
là
si parce que je sens plus tout mon côté
gauche
dès le début de l'écriture on savait que
ce serait lui parce qu'elle et moi parce
que lui Cantoni c'est un comédien qu'on
connaît depuis très longtemps la
première fois que je l'ai vu sur scène
je suis tombée amoureuse de lui je suis
tombée red morte je me suis mis
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce comédien qui
a une voix d'un autre monde un physique
d'un autre monde et puis surtout à génie
d'incarnation donc tout de suite quand
on a parlé du personnage de la mort on
savait que ce serait Luc on l'a écrit
pour lui
pour pouvoir de l'inconscient
c'est cette pensée à moi mon petit
bonhomme ça me fera des vacances ce qui
m'amuse c'est son détachement
son flegme vraiment
quand il est mis en face ça se flag mais
en face de la panique de Florence et ben
évidemment l'écart
le rire vient de là je pense il n'est là
dedans c'est vraiment c'est comme un
vieux couple
bonne nuit
j'avais peur du noir
comme toute maladie on finit par
l'apprivoiser en fait c'est horrible
mais il y a une manière de vivre avec
son anxiété ou avec sa peur de la mort
c'est finalement de l'accepter ou en
tout cas de finir par l'aimer parce
qu'elle nous définit c'est aussi moi
cette peur de la mort elle me définit
elle affecte je suis comédienne
certainement donc il faut avoir de la
tendresse pour ces troubles sinon sinon
c'est l'enfer ça fait trop longtemps
j'en ai marre de vous j'en ai marre
[Musique]
un petit peu c'est un personnage qui la
honte mais en fait je pense qu'elle le
hante aussi c'est assez marrant c'est à
dire la relation entre les personnages
moi c'est ce que j'ai ressenti au fur et
à mesure des scènes quand on est c'est
qu'en fait c'est pas sens unique donc là
vous en avez pour
deux ans
le spectacle la tournée
et d'ailleurs il y a une très belle
jolie scène quand il lui s'en va parce
que elle part en tournée donc là en fait
elle aura moins ce type d'angoisse et
donc ils vont plus voir voilà et donc il
y a une scène de pas d'adieu mais de
revoir ou ce qui est il y a beaucoup
d'émotions
ce n'est pas manquer
[Musique]
Florence elle sentir pas mieux que
personne elles sont tires avec ce
qu'elle a à sa portée
[Musique]
j'avais aussi un peu envie de montrer
qu'il y a pas de honte et que il y a pas
de honte à prendre des médicaments et
qu'il y a pas de honte à essayer de se
soigner avec tous les moyens du bord
possible du moment ça nous permettait de
vivre
le problème
si vous boitez vous prenez une béquille
non alors
tous les effets secondaires et tout
c'est surtout ça la vraie ambition caché
c'est de dire aux gens qui souffrent
n'ayez pas peur d'en parler vous soigner
c'est l'amour aussi qu'il a tient en vie
ça fait partie aussi de sa résurrection
elle va presque tomber amoureuse en
fantasme on reste pour rester en vie
parce qu'il y a que l'amour qui nous
tient à peu près heureux
je voulais aussi montrer ce que c'est
qu'elle célibataire à 45 ans est-ce que
c'est aussi duché de mecs qui sont pas
pour nous aussi parce qu'on voit bien
que Florence voilà elle va d'abord
choisir un mec qui a beaucoup trop jeune
pour elle ou trop beau ou trop jeune en
tout cas on voit ça comme on veut après
d'un homme qui a l'air d'être
responsable mais qui finalement manque
de fantaisie Pascal était aussi
impossible impossible amour donc
finalement il y a eu jeune et faible le
père responsable l'ami fidèle et le
belâtre l'inatteignable voilà et ces
quatre hommes là ils forment peut-être
l'homme idéal de Florence
ma chérie
la vie triomphe quand on peut la faire
triompher il faut prendre ce qui est à
notre portée pour continuer à rester en
vie et quand il y a l'amour quand il y a
la scène la vie est assez belle
finalement
[Musique]